Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
Heat. Heat.
Hey, hey, hey.
Hey
hey hey
don't Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
There you are.
>> Hey,
>> live Jimmy.
>> Hi
>> everybody. Welcome to this special
edition of a live stream of the Jimmy
Door Show because we have a special
guest with us. That's the whole point of
it. Professor Yang is a Beijing based
educator, writer, and advocate for
education reform. Known for his work in
promoting creativity, critical thinking,
and global citizenship in Chinese
schools. He holds a bachelor's degree in
English literature from Yale University.
And uh he gained international attention
in 2024 for his viral prediction about
foreseeing Donald Trump's return to
power and US Iran conflict and the US
losing that war based on historical
patterns and game theory. Welcome to the
show, Professor Yang. Thank you for
showing up. I appreciate it.
>> Thanks, Jimmy. I'm a huge fan of your
show. I've been watching for like five,
six years now.
>> Wow. I'm very flattered. That makes me
feel good. Uh I'm completely enthralled
with your videos and explanations. of
what's happening with the Iran war. It's
really kind of mind-blowing. I've
learned so much already in the short
time just watching you. And uh could you
just give us a update now here? Here
here we are uh March 10th, Tuesday.
Where do you see with the state of
affairs?
>> Right. Uh so I made a prediction that
the United States would start a war with
Iran in order to maintain empire. Um and
that's exactly what's happening right
now. America is an empire in decline and
we can tell because uh 5% of uh white
American girls in their 20s are on only
fans. Young people are broke. Uh they
try to make money on uh by by gambling
in cryptocurrency.
Um there's massive inequality in China.
Uh sorry, there's massive inequality in
America. Uh Congress is deadlocked. Um
politicians politicians no longer
represent the best interests of the
people. Um America has become an argu uh
the US dollar has debased in value. And
so these are all the signs of an empire
in decline. Another uh sign is an empire
lashes out against the world. So the so
the empire engages in these silly
pointless wars in order to maintain uh
hegemony through force and violence. And
we saw that most clearly, most vividly
uh in January when Delta Force went in
to kidnap Maduro uh a sovereign
president of a sovereign nation and that
goes against national law. And now we're
seeing in Iran is the same uh situation
where America is desperate. It's trying
to save the petro dollar and to do that
they're trying to knock out Iran uh and
impose a much a government that is much
more friendly to the interests of
American empire and that's what's
happening today.
>> I mean but
how this seems to be destroying the
petro dollar. Am am I wrong? What am I
missing? And how did they miscalculate
this in such a way to not see that
exactly what is happening would happen
that Iran would knock out their military
bases in the GCC states and uh it's all
over then so now they have closed the
straight of four moves so isn't this
actually did they not realize that they
would close the straight of war moves
did they not realize this would probably
kill the petro dollar and even crash our
own economy what do you say to that
>> well so the major sign of An empire
decline is hubris. An empire was capable
of self-reflection. An empire recognized
the strategic capabilities of its
adversaries. An empire would not decline
because an empire would engage in
innovation, would engage in the um um
self-reflection that was necessary to
maintain the empire. So the issue was
the 2003 um Iraq war when America in
about two weeks time was able to steam
through uh steamroll the Iraqis um and
overthrow uh Saddam Hussein. But people
forget that by 2003
Iraq was a depleted degraded nation. It
did not have air defense and so it
cannot protect itself from American
attacks. And you know when Saddam
Hussein was was advised by his generals
to develop air defense, his response was
there's absolutely no point. We can't
defeat the Americans. So the Americans
are silly enough to come attack us. Let
them. But I don't think they will
because if they knock us out, then Iran
becomes the regional superpower. And so
they wouldn't do that. Um but obviously
they did do that. And now um and that um
allowed Iran to become the regional
superpower of that region. So it's
really hubris. Um you overestimate your
own strengths and you have contempt for
your enemies and that's why um we are in
the situation. Donald Trump really
believe that Iran would be another
iteration of Venezuela where they would
go in decapitate the regime kill the
Ayatollah and there would be a new
president a new alatola who would be
amendable to negotiating with the
Americans and then he would have great
television for the next week. um any
they can they cannot possibly um
anticipate that the Iranians would be
resilient that they would be so resolved
that the people would be so unified and
now they are in a world of hurt and
Donald Trump himself um in the press
conference said that look I was given
bad advice uh he names Jared Kushner
Steve Wickoff
um and and Peter Hess and saying that
they told me that this would be quick
and easy and that's why I did this.
So that do you again uh how could even
even you know amateurs like Steve Whit
and Jared Kushner when it comes to
foreign rel how could they not see this
coming right I'm not m I'm not
overreacting that this is is this
threaten the petro dollar or do you
think this will end the petro dollar
>> well it's really a question of what your
interests are right so we're assuming
that um they all want to defend the
American empire. But let's assume that
for whatever reason they want to end the
American empire. They want to cause this
disastrous war in the Middle East.
America is so embarrassed that it must
retreat back into the Western
Hemisphere. What would happen? Well,
Israel would become the dominant power
in the Middle East and they would
achieve something called the Greater
Israel Project. And you know Na Natavi
Bennett who is the former prime minister
of Israel and who was expected to become
the next prime minister of Israel once
Nanyahu leaves the world stage. He said
that Turkey is new Iran. So this tells
you that the Israelis are thinking far
ahead that after this war in Iran is
over they'll still go after Turkey. Why?
Because in the greater Israel project,
which is what they believe that God
promised their ancestor Abraham, they
will have control from all the Middle
East, from the Nile to the Euphrates,
that includes Iraq, that includes
Turkey, that includes parts of Saudi
Arabia, that includes parts of Egypt.
So, um, it's really a question of what
Oh, no. Good.
>> You know what? You froze for a second
and you you froze right at the moment
where you said it's really a question of
>> what the end goals are here.
>> What do you think the strategy and the
purpose is here? Because Donald Trump
has never really articulated a purpose
and a strategy. So, that makes you
wonder what they're really trying to
accomplish here.
Well,
I I'll give you my guess of what they're
try. They're trying to turn Iran into
Syria, meaning they're trying to turn it
into a failed state with uh and and
divide it up into ethnicities. And so it
kind of fights each other over water. Um
and then so they lose all their power
and then the the the the hegeon in the
region, the the big power would become
Israel. Am I wrong about this?
No, I completely agree with that
assessment and we know because of how
America is conducting this war. So the
first problem is that the Americans have
yet to articulate a clear coherent
strategy what the military objectives
are. The reason why you want to do that,
the reason why you don't want to
articulate a strategy is you you would
then be contained or bounded by your
strategy. If it's about um helping
democracy protesters, then you would not
be bombing civilians, right? remember
the first day um they bombed a school a
girl school in the south of of Iran and
they killed about 170 school girls and
now there's credible evidence that it
was actually an American tomahawk
missile that killed uh the these girl
school girls um the Americans have
struck a damination plant in Iran uh oil
pots that are being used to provide fuel
for civilian purposes were struck by the
Israelis and now if you go to Tran the
capital. It's basically the apocalypse.
It's just a black um sky. And so if
you're intent on um helping the Iranians
achieve democracy, you wouldn't be doing
this. So I think that you're absolutely
right in in that they're trying to to
degrade Iran's capacity to be a nation
state and they're trying to balconize uh
the country and have uh divide and rule
>> and and do you do you think they'll be I
mean so when they attack things like the
water desalinization
plants or their oil reserves
um doesn't that have the opposite
effect? Doesn't that make it less likely
that that strategy will work of dividing
the country or or or nor am I wrong?
>> Right. So in theory in a war of
attrition you don't want to do that
because you want to turn the people
against the government. So when you
destroy critical civil infrastructure it
has the opposite effect. But we assume
it's a war of attrition, but it could
also be a war of destruction where
they're trying to destroy everything in
which case um it doesn't matter if the
civilian population supports the
government because everything is
destroyed. Um so right now uh Iran is
suffering a lot suffering under a lot of
envir environmental pressure. So if you
destroy uh water infrastructure, dams,
reservoirs, desitation plants, then the
people of Iran, 92 million people um
would be forced to immigrate elsewhere.
They would forced to they would be
forced to flee to uh Europe basically.
And that may be the end goal. Now I know
this is terrible to think about, but it
does explain why they're doing what
they're doing. We assume that they're
interested in regime change and they've
articulated um that their goal is regime
change, but it's entirely possible their
goal is just is just to destroy Iran as
a civilization.
>> And so let me ask you quickly, did uh is
this playing out the way you thought it
would play out? And has anything
surprised you that has happened and or
hasn't happened?
This is not this is not turning out the
way I thought it would turn out because
if you go back to the 2003 Iraq war even
though they were intent on regime change
they still went through the bureaucratic
protocol process of you know trying to
win public support or providing evidence
of weapons of mass destruction. Colin
Powell made a point of going United
Nations and making a case in front of
the security council and um so they they
respected the constitution. They
respected the international rulesbased
order. They respected the opinions of
the American people. None of this is
true in this instance. Um the vast
majority of American people were against
this war to begin with and they're still
opposed to uh this war. There's already
rumors of America using ground troops.
So, it seems as though this uh
government, this Trump government, they
have a script in place and they just
want to achieve this script regardless
of the consequences, regardless of the
political push back.
And that's and that's what's surprising.
So, a theory is that this is not really
a political war. It's an esqueological
war. And you know, we we know and we can
suspect this because um there there's
been complaints about this commander,
this American commander who told his
soldiers to be not afraid of this war
because this is a war uh willed by God.
This is all part of God's divine plan.
And Donald Trump is just a tool, a
mechanism in order for God to achieve
the end of the world, to bring back
Jesus and usher in the messianic age.
And we just look at um how the Israelis
are behaving, we just look at how these
Christian Zionists are behaving, how
Peter Hexaf is behaving, that is perhaps
the ultimate purpose of this war in
Iraq.
>> So you think that the ultimate purpose
for people like Pete Hegsth
and let's say uh Benjamin Netanyahu, do
you you think the ultimate purpose is
the end of the world? So is is that
really what what you're saying? Did I
hear that right?
Yes, unfortunately um I am forced to
come to this conclusion just based on
how the war is being conducted at this
point because again from a military
political perspective it doesn't make
any sense. The the Donald Trump has
actually has actually made no or no
effort to present credible evidence that
Iran is a threat to the American people.
um be in January he talked about how um
the the government in Iran was killing
protesters and that might have been a
legitimate reason but we've never heard
anything about this again. You know
during the State of the Union address he
said that he will never allow Iran to
achieve a nuclear weapon and both the
Democrats and and the Republicans
applauded this. Um but now he he doesn't
talk about that as well. So it's very
confusing as to what he wants. But so
we're just forced to assume that maybe
there's a deeper, more evil, more insane
plan going on. And the Christian
Zionists are very powerful people in
America. And so what they want to do is
this. They want to force a regional
configration in the Middle East that
will draw in the world. when Iran is
destroyed, Israel will become the
greater Israel project and will achieve
the pax Judea. This will allow certain
things to happen. Um for example, they
will be able to destroy the Alaxic
mosque which is the third holiest site
in the Islamic world and build Solomon's
temple, rebuild Solomon's temple, um the
third temple. Then they will bring the
Jews back from the diaspora. So all the
Jews in the diaspora in America, in
Britain will come back. And you're like,
well, they they're very wealthy. They're
very very well established. It doesn't
matter because they have mechanisms to
force them to come back because of the
going anti-semitism in America and
around the world right now. You know, a
lot of the anti anti-semitism you find
online, it's actually being
manufactured.
Um, and there are a lot of false flags,
right? So for example, the most bling
example is Australia, Bond Beach. But
there are but you will see more examples
of false flags against Jews in order to
scare the Jewish diaspora to return to
Jerusalem. And this is very important if
they are to achieve their end times uh
prophecy. And once the uh Jews are able
to build the greater Israel project,
once they achieve the third temple and
once the Jewish diaspora return to um uh
Jerusalem, then this will initiate
something called the war of Gaul and Mog
where the entire world uh attacks and
marches against Jerusalem. And people
can speculate as to what the war of Gog
and Mog will will be about. But if you
just look at what people what these
Christian Zionists are saying online,
they believe that Gawk and Mog are
Russia and Persia, right? A combination
of the Orthodox world and the Islamic
world will march against uh Pax Judeica.
And at the worst of times, when all hope
seems lost, that's when God will
intervene to save his chosen people, the
Jews. That means the return of Jesus uh
and the coming of the messianic age.
According to Christian Zionist, the
moment that re that Jesus returns,
there'll be the rapture where they'll
all ac ascend to um heaven before the
final battle commences. And so what
they're really trying to do is they're
trying to accelerate um the end times to
force God's hand and usher in the
messianic age. And they believe that
that's the true test of your faith. How
willing are you act? How willing are you
uh willing to act in order to achieve
God's divine plan?
So, it's I've been told most of my life
that the religious nuts, zealots, and
you know, suicide bombers are Muslims
and they're they don't have they don't
respect life and they want to kill
everybody and you too. And uh but it
seems to me that this has really been a
propaganda from the Zionists and Israel
to get Christians and Muslims fighting
each other. So that exactly what is they
could happen is that Israel could take
over the Middle East and and get the
United States out of there. So how does
so it's it seems obvious like I always
say I'm a C student so if I can figure
this out I know they know this stuff. So
how does the United States not know that
Israel really wants them out of there?
How do they not know that Israel really
wants us fighting their wars with
Muslims and that they're really not our
enemy because they weren't? Um ho how
does this I again like if I know this
how do they not know it and why are they
why would Donald Trump and everybody
right now who's in charge of things
who's people who are above Donald Trump
why would they allow us to be uh kicked
out of the Middle East like that and
give it over to Israel
>> right so I think the main reason is that
these religious fanatics have spent
centuries planting the seeds embedding
embedding themselves into power so that
they would um control all levels of
power in the western world. So let me
give give you an example of this. It is
it's always been assumed that Jeffrey
Epstein um was a MSAD agent responsible
for a honeypot operation on his island.
Uh you know Bill Gates, Bill Clinton
would go and he would film them in
compromising positions and then he would
blackmail them. But if you actually read
the Epstein emails, what you would
recognize is that he wasn't actually
doing blackmail.
Um, in fact, these very famous, powerful
people like Bill Gates, Ellen Mus, they
were trying to become his friend. You
know, Bill Gates was asked, "Why were
you hanging out with um Jeffrey
Epstein?" And Bill Gates response was,
"Well, I was trying to get money from
him for my foundation." And that sounds
that sounds kind of weird, like you're
you're the richest man in the world. Why
are you begging Jeffrey Epstein for
money? And the answer is that because
Jeffrey Epstein was an operative for a
very powerful organization. It the
emails don't tell us um what the
organization is. Uh but look, he was
involved in um Libya. He was involved in
the great financial crisis. He seemed to
have a pulse of all geopolitical events.
And he said that you know what, if we
can anticipate geopolitical events, we
can make a lot of money. But that all
can also mean that if we can manipulate
geopolitical advance, we can make um a
lot of money. There are rumors that he
was somehow involved in 911 as well
because we only have access to at most
50% of his emails. Then you ask yourself
what organization would he represent?
And the closest speculation, okay, and
again this is speculation, is the
possibility that he was a
representative, a political operative of
the Chabbat Lubberich, which Toro
Carlson mentioned uh in his in a
monologue uh a few days ago. Tbat
Lubberich has been around for a couple
of centuries. And they are messianic
Jews who want to usher in uh the end
times. And another piece of evidence to
to suggest that Shabbat Lubovich is very
powerful is that Jared Kushner, the
son-in-law of Donald Trump, he is a
Shabbat Lubich family. His entire family
is is is part of of this movement based
in Brooklyn. And what is Jed Kush
Kushner doing now? Well, he and Steve
Wickhall are Trump's envoys to peace in
Ukraine, right? Then they went to Russia
to negotiate peace with Putin. Then they
went to Ukraine to negotiate peace with
Zilinski. They're very close to
Netanyahu. And during these Iran
negotiations, they were Trump's peace
envoys. But you know, during the
negotiations, Steve Wickoff went on TV
and said that he suspects the Iranians
are a couple of weeks away from um
weapons grade uranium enrichment, which
is which for him is to say that the
Iranians are negotiating negotiating in
bad faith. So he wasn't looking to reach
an agreement with the Iranians. He was
looking to uh sabotage torpedo
negotiations. And so is it possible that
Jared Kushner and Steve Wickoff they are
trying to manipulate geopolitical events
in a certain way that achieves their
esquetology that they are operatives of
um religious individuals and they
there's a script in place and they are
just the actors in this script. So the
Shabbat Lubovich movement um is
something that we can look at also the
Freemasons, right? Because the
Freemasons are the ones who control the
national security apparatus in America.
Um and a third of US presidents have
been Freemasons. The most famous
Freemason of course was Harry S. Truman.
He was a 33rd degree Freemason, the
highest level Freemason. He was the 33rd
president of the United States. and he
was the one who ordered the dropping of
nuclear bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
which sit on the 33rd um um latitude. Um
so are all these coincident coincidence?
I'm not really sure. Okay. But it seems
as though there are very powerful people
who are extremely religious and they
believe that they've uncovered God's
plan and they are they they are
patiently methodically embedding
embedding embedding themselves into
power so that they can achieve their
esquetology and they feel as though this
is the moment this is the moment we've
been waiting for for 500 years and
another 5 10 years and we will have
achieved our plan and that's why we see
so much anxiety in the world. That's why
we we see so much desperation in the
world right now.
>> And so can you what is the con? So if
Kushner and Whitov are negotiating with
Russia and Ukraine and also with Iran
and Israel in the Middle East and they
are part of this uh Shabbat uh Lubuitz
which wants to bring about the end
times. Tell me the connection then
between Russia and Ukraine and what's
happening right now with the Israel,
United States and Iran.
>> Okay, so again this is speculation um
but one possible connection is this the
war um in Ukraine was started in order
to initiate World War II in order to to
compel force and American response.
Right? Because if the war in Ukraine is
successful, then Russia would control
onethird of the world's carbohydrates
and much of the world's energy
resources. Another thing that's very
important is that the war in Ukraine uh
would severely damage the European
economy. And you could argue from a
conspiratoral perspective that was
intentional. Why? Because in the chabbat
lubber esquetology,
Europe is great enemy. Why? Because if
you if we go back um 2,000 years, the
Jews and the Romans were great
adversaries.
And so the Romans need to be destroyed.
They need to be avenged for because it's
it was the Romans who destroyed the
second temple. And who are the heroes
and the ancestors? Uh sorry, the
descendants of the Romans, Western
Europe, right? Um, so and and and so you
you see this massive influx of Islamic
refugees into Western Europe that's
causing a lot of social uh disunityity,
a lot of social conflict. And you ask
yourself, were they really that silly as
to not know that these millions and
millions of Muslim immigrants would
destroy their social fabric? Okay, so
again, this is all speculation. All
right. But that's a connection um
between Ukraine and this esquetology.
Now uh because of this war in Ukraine,
the Americans are forced to respond by
invading Iran. There's another con
connection in that um Turkey.
>> So So are you can I just stop? Are you
saying that
>> part of the calculation for the United
States to attack Iran was the fact that
Russia is winning the war in Ukraine?
That was those are connected,
>> right? Right. So, so, so, so let let me
explain. For 200 years, um, the
Anglo-American Empire had a very basic
understanding of the world. The
Anglo-American Empire is low population.
The rest of the world is high
population. So, how do you maintain your
empire throughout the entire world?
Well, you do so by controlling sea lanes
um for trade purposes. But what this
means is that you can never allow a
power to emerge in Eurasia that could
unify the Eurasian cayenet and create a
trade block that is continental and
which can negate Anglo-American sea
power. Okay, this is called the Mckender
thesis. And so that's people believe
that's why America entered World War I
and World War II because the great fear
is that Germany could unify Eurasia and
create this continental trade block. And
so uh Anglo-American Empire is heavily
invested in creating as much
disunityity, chaos and conflict as much
as possible in Europe and in Asia. Um so
if Russia is able to conquer Ukraine and
Russia is able to control uh
carbohydrates and energy and resources,
then what Russia can do is then have a
trade block agreement with Iran and
China. And that would create this
Eurasian heartland that would negate um
American sea power and basically cause
the um US dollar to collapse in value
and this $40 trillion dollar debt that
America has would just blow up in the
face of America uh leading to widespread
depression and unrest. So the argument
is that America invaded Iran in order to
make sure that this massive trade block
between Russia, Iran and China could not
emerge and and that's a very rather re
and and that's why they had to go in and
start this war.
So, okay. Um,
that's is still So, but so how does then
Venezuela So, do you think Venezuela was
because So, how does Venezuela fit into
this?
>> Yeah, great question. Okay. So, um, so
Trump is not actually interested in this
esquetology. He he himself has a
different understanding of the world
which is America first. But America
first doesn't mean you end empire.
America first just means you change the
nature and structure of the empire. So
um America first means we don't want to
involve oursel in the Middle East
anymore. Let's just stick to the western
hemisphere, the manual doctrine or the
dono doctrine and have control over the
resource of the western hemisphere. Then
we no longer have to deal with the rest
of the world. We no longer have to fight
these sandbox wars. So and that's why
Trump is threatening Greenland, Canada,
Mexico, Colombia, Cuba. I mean it's all
part of his larger um vision. Um
Venezuela was was almost like a trap
where maybe these foreign policy hawks
neocons convince him uh to go into
Venezuela and it would be a quick and
easy win and it was and because it was
such a quick and easy win that u made
Trump too arrogant. They gave him hubris
and believe that you know what the
American military thought of force
they're invincible. So if I can do that
in Venezuela, I can do that in um Iran
as as well. So that's why they had to do
Venezuela first to convince Trump that
Iran was doable. Another reason why they
did Venezuela is um at the end of the
month, Trump will visit China. And what
Trump wants to do is negotiate a grand
bargain with China to maintain the uh
current world order where America is at
the top. And so what Trump needs to do
is basically economically strangle China
uh in order to force China to um concede
to American demands. Basically, what
America wants is for China to save the
US dollar as the as the world's reserve
currency. And you do that um if China
uses its excess household savings to
cons continue to buy US dollars, which
is a Ponzi scheme.
>> So what what is the what is the leverage
that Donald Trump has over China to get
them to go? So is he going to now
substitute Venezuelan oil for Iranian
oil? What is his leverage? China
>> right so um before China was getting its
oil from a variety of places the reality
is that China is dependent on oil
exports to to fuel its manufacturing
economy it imports about 75% of oil and
it was going only getting about 1% of
its oil from Venezuela it's getting um
um it's it's getting about 40% of its
oil from the hummus okay so not just
Iran but the entire GCC area Qatar as as
well now you've cut cut of a major
supply network uh for the Chinese. Now,
the thing is the Chinese are pramatic.
So, what Trump will say to the Chinese
is, you know, I'm sorry about this war
in the Middle East. I'm sure you've lost
your oil, but America can sell you oil.
The Western Hemisphere, Canada, America,
Mexico can sell you oil. How about that?
And and in that in this instance, it's
almost a fatal compete where China is
forced to say yes because again, China
is problematic. Uh, China is a nation of
business people
>> and so you think they'll go, "Okay,
we'll do whatever you want with Iran and
we'll just take we'll buy your oil
instead." You think that's what they'll
do?
>> Well, again, the Chinese are pramatic
and strategic. So, yes, they will agree
to this deal, but they will also
continue to support Iran with the hope
that Iran wins this war and then is able
to control the Middle East and therefore
supply uh um china with um oil. Okay.
So, so another way we're saying this is
that, you know, China could in theory
get most of its oil supply from Russia,
which is an ally. The problem with that
is that you set yourself up for
long-term risk. Um, Russia could choose
to up uh the price of its oil. Something
could happen to Russia which would
disrupt um oil oil supply. Pipelines can
be blown up, right? So, the Chinese are
pramatic. They want to have multiple
trade partners and they are not
ideological. They're perfectly happy to
trade with the Iranians, with the
Americans, with the Chinese, whoever
gives them the best price. And so for
their national strategic interest, it's
very important to have multiple trade
partners and multiple sources of
resources.
>> Uh so
so do you think this was part of the
calculation for Donald Trump to attack
Iran? was that to get the upper hand on
on China in a way and that we could we
could then start controlling their oil
supply.
>> I think Donald Trump doesn't think
geopolitically. I don't think he thinks
strategically. He thinks he thinks in
terms of television. Um there are
advisers who believe this but Donald
Trump is just interested in good TV and
Venezuela made great TV that distracted
people from the Epstein files. So, so
his advisors were like, "Iran will make
even better TV when we go decapitate the
Ayatollah uh and when the Iranians cheer
on the streets for uh regime change,
when when they shout your name in the
streets of Tran." That's what he was
probably told and um he believed it
>> and so so he's getting a big surprise.
He's it's so it's the old story of we're
going to be greeted as liberators and
then now a week into it he realizes
that's not going to happen. And so he's
been saying that he uh he he wants that
the war is basically over. And do do you
do you think that that's him trying to
do do you think he's realized that there
is no winning this war and that if he
continues it it will crash our economy
and so he's looking for an off-ramp
right now? Is that or is he not doing
that and is he going to put in ground
troops?
>> So I think Trump has dissociative
personality disorder in that he's living
in his own world. uh in this world. It's
very nice. It's very pretty and and what
he's interested in is capturing the
attention of the world and that's why
he's saying what he's saying. But at the
end of the day, he is bounded by
geopolitical reality. And um because
America is already committed to this
war, they have to win it now for the
idea of credibility. So go back to
Vietnam, right? By by 1966,
um the Pentagon experts have already
concluded that the war was not winnable,
that this war was lost. But they still
continue to fight this war because of
credibility, because an empire is a
force that imposes its reality on other
people and it creates the aura of
invincibility in inevitability. And if
um people recognized that these jungle
gorillas uh could defeat um the American
empire then all credibility would be
lost. Soviet Union would laugh in the
face of America and therefore they
continue this war even though the war
was not winnable. We will see a similar
calculus in Iran where even though the
American general staff have come to
recognition that this war is not
winnable they will continue to fight
this war in order to maintain phase
credibility. Another uh phrase that is
commonly used is sunk cost fallacy where
you go in the casino, you lose a million
dollars, and you can't leave anymore
because you're determined to win back
that million dollars. And America has
invested too much in this war already.
Billions and billion billions of dollars
in interceptors. Um, and America right
now has about 150 casualties. So, it's
too heav heavy of an investment. Also,
if America were to strategically
retreat, Iran would win. Why? Because
Iran would have control the shoo and
therefore it could impose levies on the
GCC. And now Iran would have the
financing in order to become a
superpower which would challenge uh the
greatial project. Um and and so America
could not count that possibility.
So where where do you see I mean it
seems to me
that this is going to be way worse for
the United States than Iraq, Libya, and
Syria combined and Afghanistan. This is
going to be way worse for the whole
entire world, right? This is this looks
like a legit world war. um because it
has worldwide implications for sure and
with the biggest superpowers being
United States, Russia and China and
Japan. Um
so where do you
where do you find where do you see this
going? I mean like I So do you think
Donald Trump is going to try to stop it
uh as fast as possible or do you think
it's he's going to listen to Israel and
keep it going until we're all destroyed?
>> Yeah. So unfortunately once a war starts
it achieves his own momentum and even if
Donald Trump personally want to stop
this war and I think he does uh the
military won't let him do so and the
same thing happened in Vietnam. Um this
war is going to continue to accelerate
and eventually you will see uh the
deployment of ground forces and even the
introduction of a national draft. Um in
fact um Donald Trump has is already
talking about the possibility of of a
draft. um you know there's there's a
plan to deploy National Guard throughout
the United States by April and you would
do that because you anticipate that
young people don't want to go to war and
and I and I think they're right. So I I
think there is a plan in place to force
a draft uh um onto the American American
nation. What people don't recognize is
that as you point out this is World War
II and this is global and the world will
never be the same again after this. The
question is how bad will it get? And I
think that what's happening is a
controlled demolition of the global
order which really benefit America. So I
think that over the next 5 to 10 years
there'll be three major trends that we
can anticipate. Okay. The first major
trend is deindustrialization.
Why? Because the entire global economy
is based on access to cheap oil from the
GCC. Right? Not only uh is energy based
on cheap oil but also we have to
remember that fertilizers uh plastic
products the entire
to farm to to have a much more
sustainable um food production system.
Can you can can I you know what you you
you stopped for just a second and which
when you said the entire and then it
froze for a few seconds. Could you
remember what you were saying?
>> Yeah. So the entire global economy um is
going to suffer a controlled demolition
and there will be three major trends
that will be happening in next 5 to 10
years. Okay. The first major trend is
de-industrialization
because right now the modern economy is
based entirely on access to cheap oil.
Cheap oil is the basis not just for uh
energy but also for fertilizer which
grows food also for plastic products.
Right? So when you once you lose access
to cheap oil you can no longer sustain a
modern industrial economy. You can't
have EV, you can't have AI, you can't
have data centers, which means that you
either send the urban people back to the
rural villages uh to farm or you starve
as a nation. Okay, so
de-industrialization
is will be a ma major trend um in the
near future. That's number one. Uh
number two is
um remilitarization. And the reason why
is that once this war starts, you have
to be able to protect your trade routes.
Okay? So one of the major um nations
that is suffering heavily from this war
in the Middle East is Japan because
Japan um uh depends on 75% of its oil
supply from the sh of Humus and the
prime minister Takayachi has told her
cabinet that in seven eight months we're
going to run out of oil guys. Okay. So
Japan needs to figure out how to use its
military to control supply networks, how
to create trade access. And so what you
will see over the next 5 to 10 years is
the massive remm militarization of
nation states. Okay. And the third major
trend is something called mercantalism.
Mercantalism is basically just
self-sufficient economies. before. Um,
so we're we're now used to a global
economy where you can buy avocados from
Chile, where you can buy vodka from
Russia any day, any time um of of the
year, but that's not really sustainable.
And so um in the future there'll be
there'll be regional trade blocks that
are controlled by a uh local hedgeimon.
So basically we're we are witnessing the
shattering of the old global order, the
emergence of a uh much more splintered
multipolar system.
>> So you're saying that there people are
they're going to depopulate metropolitan
areas and people will be going back in
to live on farms. Is that what you're
saying?
>> I'm exa Yes, thank you. Yes, that's
exactly what I'm saying. They have
absolutely no choice in the matter
because again urban centers are
dependent on globalization and access to
cheap energy and cheap food. Once global
trade stops and once um access to cheap
energy goes away then you are forced to
grow your own food supply. Urban centers
don't do that. Rural centers do that.
Right? So you need to shift the
population from urb urban areas to rural
areas if you want to sustain yourself as
a nation.
Uh so a has the
seems like I mean so many people warned
against uh doing this this is probably
why you know uh Joe Biden and Barack
Obama didn't do this was because they
knew what the consequences
were going to be. And so has the has the
United States already lost this war and
Donald Trump just doesn't know it or
does he know it?
Yeah. So I think this war is unwinable.
Um and the moment that you go into Iran
and start this war u the moment that
Iran closes of Hummus and commits to
total war
then then this war is lost. So Donald
Trump is interesting because if you go
back to his first term there are clear
indications that he would eventually
start this war. Okay. Um so remember in
his first term he was doing things that
were extremely controversial and which
no uh American president ever did before
because they thought it it would be not
in the best interest of America. So
things he did was he moved the American
embassy from Tel Aiv to Jerusalem. Um he
assassinated General Kasam Sulammani uh
who was the Iranian Middle East envoy
and who was working actually with
Americans to contain ISIS, the threat of
ISIS in in Iraq and um and and then
there were the Abraham Accords which
brought together um Saudi Arabia and and
Israel. And so he was doing all these
things that from American foreign polic
for foreign policy perspective was
actually going to destabilize the Middle
East in the long term because it would
bring a conflict um Israel and and Iran.
Jared Kushner was basically uh Trump's
de facto Middle East envoy. He was
flying around the region and having uh
private negotiations with the Saudis um
with with basically every everyone. Um
so there was a real danger that um given
Trump's actions in the first term uh he
would eventually launch a war against
Iran. Um the Israelis in the first term
really thought that Trump was Cyrus the
great which is the Messiah right the
Persian Messiah that is celebrate
celebrating in the Bible and Trump and
that might have gone into Trump's head
because if you go to Mara Lago there's
actually a replica of the art of the
covenant in Mara Lago if you look at
his biggest supporters were actually
pro-Israel people. So the most famous of
course is Miriam Adlesen who gave him
$100 million.
A few months ago they had dinner at the
White House and Miam Adlesen said that
she hopes that he runs for a third term
and if he does run for a third term then
she will commit $250 million to ensure
his reelection. So it seemed as though
from the very beginning because Jared
Kushner who was very close again with
Chad Rubber uh and with Netanyahu in
fact Netanyahu stayed at uh Jar
Kushner's u child bedroom um uh bedroom
when he visited uh New Jersey. Um there
there was there's clear signs that
Israel has control over Trump and Trump
himself doesn't really think that long
term. So it seems as though Trump is
being manipulated into the situation and
he doesn't really appreciate the
consequences because he doesn't think
you know ahead
>> and
so how far away what are the chances of
nuclear weapons happening now I know
Iran doesn't have them uh but Israel
does and Israel also has the Samson
option which uh do you think they'll
sample them option is if they feel like
they're
existential threat of being annihilated
as a state that they will then nuke all
the other big states or countries in the
world and bring again bring about the
end times. Is it is that the what the
Samson option is and do you think that
there will be nuclear weapons used in
this conflict?
>> Right. So the Samson option is only used
if the state of Israel is threatened and
right now the state of Israel is not
threatened. In fact, okay, and I I know
this is going to sound really weird. The
Iranians are doing the Israelis a favor
by bombarding Tel Aviv, right? So, let
me explain why. There are two centers of
gravity in the state of Israel. There's
Tel Aviv, which is the open cosmopolitan
democratic Israel. It's the Astanazi u
uh Issue. It's a European Israel. Then
you have Jerusalem, which is the
conservative religious theocracy. Right?
So there's almost like a power struggle
in Israel to determine the soul of the
nation. And because the Iranians are
bombarding Tel Aviv and not Jerusalem,
this is forcing the Aski Jews, the
European Jews, the liberal democratic
cosmopolitan Jews to leave uh for
Europe, which now makes Jerusalem the
center of gravity in the state of
Israel. So these religious fanatics um
in Israel believe that this war is
actually good because it will make uh
Israel much more theocratic. It will
abandon its um facade of western
democracy and just embrace its
theocracy. And these religious Jews
believe that that is what god wants. So
I I I don't want to go too much into the
theology. what they believe is that what
they're trying to achieve the kingdom of
David. Okay? And what does that mean?
David
um had the best relationship with God
because David was humble. David prayed
to God every single day. And why David
did that is because he suffered
tremendous tragedy. Um he married
Bashiba who uh but Bash Bashiba already
had a husband named Uriel Heitate. So
David had him assassinated and that's a
great crime against God. And then God
punished David uh by killing David's u
son with with with Bashibba and that
forced David to look into himself and
recognize his own limitations and
recognize the supremacy of God. So he
redeemed himself redemption, right? And
that's what these religious extremists
in Israel want to do. They want to
create this war that shatters the
illusion uh of Israel as a modern day
democracy and force the Israeli Jews to
um redeem themselves in the eyes of God
to submit themselves fully to the power
and embrace of of God. And so so another
saying this is that the people in charge
of Israel have mapped this out and it's
it's it's going according to their plan.
Wow. Uh,
so I mean, so who do you think uh
what do you think is going to be
how do you see this ending for the
United States, Israel, Iran, and the
Gulf States? Uh, I mean, even China and
Russia. How do you see this ending?
>> Right. So again there's an
esquetological script in place and we
just assume the esquetological script uh
is accurate. Okay. Then certain things
will happen. Okay. Um what happen is
this America will launch a ground
invasion of Iran and to do that they
need a national draft. America may spend
5 10 years in Iran and they will lose
this war because America doesn't have
the political will the manufacturing
capacity uh the resilience to fight this
war. This war because of national draft
will ignite a civil war in the United
States. Right? So America is forced to
retreat from the Middle East, close down
all its bases and um America will be
enrolled in a civil war for the next 5
to 10 years. Um low intensity civil war
but a civil war nonetheless which makes
>> what would it look like? Um um well
there are two movies that have come out
in the past year that sort of tell us
how it would look like you know one
battle after another and civil war right
so basically the entire nation splinters
into arclims that fight fight fight each
other it's low intensity um you won't
have armies march against each other but
it'll be impossible to govern the nation
you'll have sieges of New York City of
Boston you'll have um massive sectarian
warfare between the left and and the
Right. Minnesota, what happened in
Minnesota in January is basically an
appetizer. Um, so so um it's it would be
very complicated, but there'll be a lot
of sectarian violence in in America,
which then forces America out of the
world. America is forced to retreat back
into the Western Hemisphere. Okay. So
that so that's America.
Once Iran and America are destroyed, um
the GCC is also destroyed in this war as
well because people don't appreciate how
vulnerable the GCC uh is. GCC imports 80
89% of its food. Um it it's a desert so
it needs to import food from other
places. Um
the desalination plants provide 60% of
its water because it doesn't have
organic freshwater supplies and its most
workers are imported from the rest of
the world. So if the shumus is closed um
if their economies collapse then their
nations collapse as well. Okay. So the
GCC it is done. Uh they're gone. Uh they
will wither back into the desert. That
so that's a GCC. Iran uh will be
destroyed as a nation state. uh it will
suffer from a lot of issues like such as
water scarcity and a lot of of Iranians
will die in this war. So they will need
they will need time to build back but in
the long term uh Iran will come back
because this is Persia and they have
3,000 years of civilization and so these
are really resilient and creative uh
people.
This war will enable Russia to complete
its major military objective in Ukraine,
which is the capture of Odessa. Okay, so
imagine um a year from now, a month from
now, who knows? Okay, but America sends
in ground troops into Iran. That means
that um America is now um completely
focused on Iran. That allows Russia to
march against Odessa. the Europeans have
to come in to reinforce Odessa. Um, but
the Europeans don't have the political
will. They don't have the uh number of
soldiers. They don't have the manu
manufacturing capacity to fight this
war. So this will cause civil conflict
in Europe as well which will lead to
regime change in Germany, in Britain, in
France. So Europe implodes and Russia
now controls uh Ukraine.
According to this esquetology, this is
really interesting. At this point,
Russia and Israel will work together to
divide up Turkey. The reason why is that
sovereign um Turkey is part of the
greater Israel project. Okay. So, um
Israel wants the south of of Turkey,
Anatolia. For the Russians, there's
something called the third Rome
prophecy, which is to say that Moscow
will become the third Rome and rule over
the Orthodox world. To do that, what
they need to do according to this
esquetology is
return the Greeks to Constanapole, which
is Istanbul. So in other words, perhaps
um Russia and Israel already have a deal
in place to split up Turkey in the long
term. Okay. Um and um China is actually
not part of esquetology, which is say
that the occultists who came up this
esquetology assume that China is forced
to turtle up because of the geopolitical
uh environment. So uh so so China's not
really part of the equation. Then what
Israel will do is something create
something called the Pax Judea. All
right. So the Pax Judeica is basically
Jerusalem is the center of the world and
from from Jerusalem Israel is able to
control trade and industry in Africa in
the Middle East and it controls the sort
of moves. It controls oil production in
the Middle East and uh and therefore
it's able to achieve AI
and an AI surveillance state. So what
they did in Gaza, they'll scale out to
the rest of the Middle East. They will
import laborers, tens of millions of
laborers in order to be the cheap labor
of this packa. These laborers will come
from India, China, and the Philippines.
Remember before this war started uh Modi
the Indian prime minister went to
Jerusalem and had a very good meeting
with Nanyahu and the reason why is
Israel wants to import Indian labor for
to rebuild Israel after this war.
Sorry. Yeah. So
uh so Israel also so this is the thing I
that no one is talking about is that
Israel also wants the United States out
of the Middle East. They want
>> Yes.
>> They want they want to destroy SenCom.
Correct.
>> Yes.
>> And so if you know this and I know this,
how in the hell does Pete Hegs not know
this or Donald Trump not know this or
Tulsi Gabbard not know this? How does
the news stations not how does no one
else is talking about this that Israel
actually wants us to get out of the
Middle East so they could be the
superpower there? How does nobody know
this?
>> Okay, so there are different reasons.
Okay, the first of course is hubris
where America believes it is invincible
that it will eventually triumph in Iran
and honestly the people in Washington
live live in an echo chamber, right? So
they don't watch your show, they don't
watch Sarah Carlson, they just listen to
uh New York Times to CNN and these
talking heads just tell them exactly
what they want to hear. Right? This is
the boomer generation. Okay? So number
one is hubris. Um uh second is issue is
escology where the American government
is infiltrated by Christian Zionists, by
Freemasons, by uh people loyal to uh
Israel um Zionists, right? and they
control the levers of power and so they
can dictate policy uh even though it's
bad politics. Okay, that's number two.
Um number three is that for the longest
time, Israel was the pitbull of America
in the Middle East. In fact, if you go
back to the creation of Israel uh in
1948 and then before that the Belfar
Declaration, it seemed as though the
British created Israel as a um as a ford
base for the Anglo-American Empire,
right? Because Israel was essentially a
settled colony of white Europeans in in
the in the Arab Arab world. And the
point of Israel was create as much
instability as possible in the Middle
East. and it served its function really
really well. And so for the longest
time, Israel just served the interest of
empire. And so empire today still
believes that uh Israel is still useful.
And what they don't recognize is that
Israel has been plotting to replace the
American empire for a very long time.
You know, there's there's actually a
YouTube clip. Uh you you can go on
YouTube and watch this. But you know
Nanyahu is walking up the stairs and the
journalist asked him, "Hey uh prime
minister, what do you have in in your
arm? What are you reading right now?"
And the book is called Rome versus the
Jews by Barry Strauss. Okay. So it goes
back to about 70 um AD when the Roman
Empire was trying to crush the Jewish
revolt and the journalist asked Nanyahu,
"Why are you reading this book?" And
Nahu's response was because it did not
go well the first time. Because it did
not go well the first time. Who is Rome
today?
>> Uh that would be us.
>> Not Iran.
>> Is that us?
>> Probably not not probably not Iran.
Okay. Probably not Russia. Yeah.
Probably United States. Okay. So he's
saying that eventually we're going to
come into conflict with America and we
need to prepare. Right. It didn't go
well the first time. We need to make
sure this time we win.
I again I I just am, you know, just
flumxed that we know this stuff, but
somehow the people in power seem to not
know this stuff that Donald Trump
doesn't seem to know it. And again, Pete
Heg says, Jud Tulsi Gabbard, maybe they
do. Maybe maybe you're right. Maybe
they're completely controlled by the
Freemasons and the uh Shabbad Lovitz and
all those things. And um so it so here's
the thing. No, I I saw you explain this
that the reason why this war will crash
our economy is because our economy, our
stock market is propped up by all the
money that the Gulf states like Saudi
Arabia and UAE and uh Cotter and so
forth. They put they put in they invest
into our AI here and that is propping up
our stock market. And so now because of
this war, the straight of Hormuz is
closed and they can't make any money.
Plus, they're being bombed by Iran. And
so people are fleeing peuh places like
Dubai and it's not going to be an
economic center anymore. And so that
money will get pulled out of our stock
market. It's going to crash our economy.
How in the hell is the the United States
going to institute a draft in the middle
of a depression that is probably going
to be worse than the 30s and and then
also fight a war for 10 years in the
middle of a great depression with our
dollar being complete. The whole point
of us having the biggest military in the
world is because we're the reserve
currency in the world and we can just
keep printing money and making more, you
know, bombs and and um armaments. But as
soon as that goes away, we don't have
that ability anymore. So, how could
there possibly be a 10-year war? How
could we even do ground troops because
our economy is going to be tanking by
the by the time that happens? Am I wrong
about this?
Right. So, I think the idea is that when
people are desperate, they are most
likely to be afraid and therefore most
likely to be obedient. So, if you crash
the economy and people don't have any
savings, uh people don't have any hope,
um it's much easier to draft them,
right? Because if you have some money
sitting in the bank and you have a
pretty nice life, you're not going to go
go want to you're not going to want to
go fight a war uh overseas, right? So,
remember um if America had entered World
War I, sorry, World War II in 1930s,
most Americans wouldn't go. When America
entered World War II in 1941, and this
is like 10 years of Great Depression,
when people had couldn't find any work,
when people didn't have enough food to
eat, when people had to roam the country
looking for any substance, right? So,
you want to create as much fear, anxiety
as possible in America in order to force
them to go fight a war that they don't
want to fight. Um, now I agree with you
that this planet won't work, but they
don't know that. Okay, I'm sorry. I
mean, like like like like obviously that
they live in a different reality that
than we do. You know, we we we have a
more objective sense of what's going on,
but if you're watching DC, all you care
about is obtaining more power, climbing
that political ladder, and so you just
do what you're told. And unfortunately
people who go to Washington DC don't
have their own ideas. So if you have you
have an idea and these and these
precieties do do have their own ideas.
These oultists have their own
esquetology then you just do what you're
told and this leads to national suicide
and that's exactly what's happening in
America today.
So the
is this a 100% chance uh that you give
this or is this a 50% chance? What what
what would you put on it?
>> Look, I just engage in intellectual
speculation. I have no concrete evidence
to work from. I don't even know any of
the players, right? But what I'm saying
is that it turn you just look at the
past 10 years and you ask yourself why
they're happening. Well, they fit into
an esque esqueological script, including
COVID, including this war in Ukraine,
including uh the election of Donald
Trump. It seems to fit into a script.
And so you just extrapolate outwards and
you're able to figure out okay what they
have planned what the plan is next 5 10
years. Okay. But I myself don't have any
concrete evidence that any of this will
turn out. And quite honestly I have
three young kids. So I hope none of this
turns out. I hope that Donald Trump
tomorrow uh wakes up and says you know
what I made a terrible mistake. We need
to get out of the Middle East as soon as
possible. We need to focus on ensuring
that average Americans can live a decent
life. Screw the world. Let's do America
first. You know, he has this come to
Jesus moment. Okay. I hope I hope to God
that happens. Uh is that likely?
Probably not.
So
you're So okay. So what should what
should a normal what should a regular
person do who's in the United States? So
how is there any way to like so when
this economic crash happens that's it
everybody just loses all their money
what what what should people do is there
a way to protect yourself do you think
right so you know part of this escalator
plan requires depopulation as you as you
point out earlier they do tend they do
plan to kill a lot of people and and
when I mean a lot of people I mean like
over 90% of humanity will be killed over
the next 20 years okay that that is part
of the wider divine plan. And I think
that most people who die will be because
they refuse to wake up to reality
because they refuse to uh understand the
larger picture in place. So I think one
thing that's really important is for
people to have the courage to admit that
um the world is changing and to have the
faith that things will turn out uh for
the better. So basically knowledge, keep
yourself informed, you know, and that's
why shows like yours is so important,
right? Because you because during COVID,
you were actually telling people the
truth when most people didn't want to
hear the truth. Okay? So most people who
die will be because they have they lack
the courage to see the truth for what it
is. That's number one. Number two is
that
um money is a great Satan of this world.
It's a great illusion. That money is the
mechanism by which they control you. And
what you need to recognize is that true
wealth is your spirituality. True wealth
is your empathy, your humanity, your
consciousness. So focus on building
strong relations with people around you.
And just accept the fact that your money
is not going to be worth that much in a
year or two. You that vacation you have
you you have planned for the Maldes in
spring of next year, it's not going to
happen anymore. Okay? just give up these
material obsession and focus on things
that make you happy which is family,
friends, purpose, um spirituality,
creativity, um these things make you
happy and you should focus on these
things. Be kind, be generous to your
neighbors because in the future it's
these neighbors that may save your your
your
life. And the third thing um I I will
say is
um spirituality is what's really
important. You know Tar Carlson he says
this a lot but what's going to happen is
a spiritual war and it is true. Um you
know there will be lot lots of these
wars. What but the war that really
matters is a war for your heart. The war
for your faith for for your soul. And if
you just focus on being optimistic,
um then I guarantee you you will survive
the coming apocalypse. Okay? But but
again, it's your choice. It's always
your choice. Free will is the divine
principle of the universe. You have to
choose to be free. You have to choose to
be brave. You have you have to choose to
live. Um and so whatever happens will
depend a lot on personal choice.
Okay. Well, uh, it's really
there's there is no silver lining.
There's no bright spot. There's no good
news. It's all bad news.
>> No, no, no, no. I think there is a
silver lining. The silver lining is that
for the first time in our lives, people
are waking up to the truth. Right? Think
about um how people now recognize that
we're run by demons. This doesn't happen
during co This didn't happen during the
Biden years. People just chose to put
their heads in the sand. But these
Epstein fouls that are being released,
this war in Iran, it's basically
shattering the worldview of normies. And
maybe this war is actually part of of
God's final plan to bring about a global
spiritual awakening to uh heighten the
consciousness of humanity so that we
collectively can build a better world.
But if 90% of the people are dead, so so
the PE so
the people
behind is the greater Israel project,
you're saying they have a plan to have
so does that how does that connect with
the WF and and COVID and the vaccine?
How does do they all connect somehow or
is is and that is that connect to the
90% of humanity dead? How does this all
connect?
>> Well, I mean, look, you're part of the
global elite. You all believe that 8
billion people on this planet, it's not
sustainable. Uh, it's a burden on on the
planet. It's a burden on government. Um,
8 billion people want to live middle
class lives. They want air conditioning.
They want to drive SUVs. They want to
vacation in the Maldes. This is not
sustainable. But if we reduce the
population to like, I don't know, 100
million people, well, then we we can
create paradise on Earth, right? So
short-term pain but long-term gain,
right? This is how literally everyone of
the global elite thinks and behaves. Um,
and it is demonic, right? But they they
literally believe that what everything
that they're doing is for the betterment
of humanity. Everything that they're
doing is to create heaven on earth.
including these Christian Zionists,
including these WF people, anyone in the
elite believe that um I need to be like
Thanos. I need to create the Thanos
solution, you know, snap my finger and
half of humanity will disappear and then
we'll instantly have paradise on Earth.
And do you feel like people like, you
know, like Bill Gates, Jeff Bezos,
George Soros,
uh Charles Schwab, you know, the people
who seem to be the richest people in the
world, Elon Musk, these pe are they the
ones implementing this plan? Do they or
are they not or are they aware of the
plan? What what do you what do you
think?
>> I think they're leers to power. Um I
think that if we know who they are, they
don't have the real power. Um, I think
that the real powerful people are the
occultists, the heads of secret
societies who spend their time during up
these crazy schemes to conquer the
world. And they're hidden in the
shadows. Um, and they're the ones who
come up with these plans and you know,
Jeffrey Epstein, Jerk Kushner, they're
the operatives. They're the ones who
actually go out um and actually
implement the plan in in the world. And
then people like Bill Gates, Mark
Zuckerberg, they're like poster boys. um
they're the ones that capture people's
imagination. They're like PR people
basically. So I think there are
different layers to power, but the way
that people think power works is not the
way power works. Okay? Uh Donald Trump
is not the most powerful person in
America. The president of the United
States is not the most powerful person
in America. Um and the reason why is
that the president of United States is a
is a temp. I mean he he's a tempor
temporary employee, right? For four,
eight years at at most. You're not gonna
give all the power to that person.
>> Yeah. I've Yes. Well, uh what Kurt Mezer
says on my show is that if Jeffrey
Epstein, we try to figure out if he's
really dead. I think he's alive. Um and
Kurt says, "Well, if he worked for the
MSAD, he's dead. But if he worked for
the if the MSAD worked for him, then
he's alive, which means he worked for
the Rothschilds."
>> Right? So one thing that these believed
in is is the idea of reincarnation. So
they never die. They they just
reincarnate. Okay? So even if he
physically was dead, he would still be
able to reincarnate himself into another
body at uh some point. You know, like
these extremists, all right, these um
Jewish extremist, Shabbat Lubich, at the
very extreme, they believe that there's
actually only 600,000 humans in this
world. Everyone else is an animal. These
600,000
uh come from the from the splintering of
the world soul, Adam Ken. And what's
important is to bring the 600,000 people
back into Jerusalem to redeem them and
repair the world and everyone else can
just die. Who cares?
>> Wow. Okay. All right. Well, is there any
any anything else you you want to leave
us with?
>> Uh yeah, I'm sorry. it it's it's been so
depressing, but um I think it's really
important for everyone to just start to
recognize that there are much more
powerful hidden forces at work here.
Things aren't just simple as Donald
Trump not knowing what he's doing. Uh
there are these puppet masters in place
and once we start to understand this and
once we start to peel beneath the
curtain and understand what's really
going on, then we can build a better
world.
How do you know about the puppet
masters? H how I'm I'm 60 years old. I'm
just now hearing about them because of
the Jeffrey Epstein files. This is the
first time I'm hearing about anything
I'm hearing of Candace Owens has talked
about it. Now you're talking about it.
Kurt all always talks about it. But what
uh how do you know about these puppet m
these satanic occults that really are
the puppet masters? How do you know?
>> Yeah, because um I use game theory.
Okay. So, I'm just trying to figure out
uh who's really in charge. And if you
just do analysis, a game analys simple
game theory through analysis, what you
recognize is that the history that we're
taught doesn't make any sense. Now, and
I'll give you an example where you know
during the guilded age, uh Rockefeller
monopolized America's oil resources.
Question then is how was a normal person
with very little resources how was he
able to monopolize the entire national
res oil resource of America and you do
some basic research what what you
recognize is that he's he was not a
billionaire he was not a rich person he
was just an agent he was just a poster
boy for the city of London city c city
city city of London was taking all this
wealth that it generated um through the
open opium trade in China and by
stealing from India and then reinvesting
it back in America. But if the city of
London would do that, the American the
American population would rebel because
they hate Britain. They hated they hated
Britain at that time. So they needed an
agent, a poster boy uh in order to
launder all this wealth into America and
control all the national resources of
America. And that person and these
people are Rockefeller, Carnegie,
Vanderbilt, uh Morgan, right? And you
fast forward to the 1980s and then the
question then is like why was the
Pentagon
um who had spent billions in decades in
developing all this cutting edge uh
computer research? Um why were they just
giving this stuff for free to guys like
like Bill Gates and uh Steve Jobs? And
the and the answer is because they want
to create a civilian state, but if uh
the Pentagon were to sell computers to
American people, the American people
would be like, "Screw you. You guys are
the military. You guys cause a Vietnam
war. I'm not I'm not going to surrender
my personal freedom to you." There be
there'll be a a national um outcry, but
because Steve Jobs, Mark Zuckerberg,
these guys were selling the internet.
And I was like, well, you know, these
are nerds. Sure, I can trust them. Okay.
So, so the way you think power works
isn't actually how power works. Uh,
power is much more deceptive. It's
always behind the scenes manipulating
events.
>> And so, how does that lead you to
realize that there's a an occult
uh group of people that are actually
running things?
Um
because you have to ask yourself why wh
why why are they doing what they're
doing, right? Why is Jeff Epstein doing
what he's doing? And um it seems he's
involved in global affairs. It seems he
has access to anyone and everyone. So
the question you have to ask ask
yourself is who gave him this power and
why did they and why did they give him
this power? Right? And you just keep on
working backwards, okay? Working
backwards and eventually you hit into
the occultist. And so if you just, you
know, I think Kurt Mezer knows much more
about this than I do. Actually, I'll be
honest with you. I spent a lot of time
watching Kurt Mezer on your show and and
you know, he mentioned something
Frankus. He mentioned the
interdimensional digit people and that's
what got got me to research these topics
and then I was slowly able to connect
the dots. So Kurt Mezer is is is my
rabbi.
>> Okay.
Um
is so there there really is a spiritual
war happening and there really is a
satanic
cult of people that we've gotten a
glimpse of through the Epstein files
that actually run things.
>> Yep. And they've always been in power.
That's exactly right.
>> Wow. I don't know. I really don't know.
I I honestly don't know what to do. Um
anyway, um Dr. Yang, I I I appreciate
you making time for us. It's it's, you
know, you are incredibly astute about
all this more than any I've learned more
watching you than anyone else on this.
And I just can't believe that people
don't understand. I mean, how did again,
I I I keep asking the same questions.
How did the Gulf States not see this
coming? How did they not know this was
going to happen? How did they not know
they were going to get wiped out? Why
did they think that the United States
would protect them when they of course
they're only going to protect Israel?
How does it just it's all so obvious? Uh
yet it the the people who are running
things don't seem to get it. And except
everybody except Benjamin Netanyahu and
the Zionists, they get it. They know
exactly what's happening, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And they they plan this out already.
>> They what?
>> They they planned this out already.
>> Yeah.
Okay. Well, uh, uh, hopefully the United
States, hopefully they wake up.
Hopefully there's some kind of
intervention. I don't know. Dr.
Professor Yang, I really appreciate it.
You're welcome on this. I'm very
flattered that you watch my show. I
didn't wasn't
>> I love your show.
>> I I you know, I I think you're the best
news source uh on TV right now, even
though you're not actually on TV and
actually you're not a journalist, but
yes, I I I I really admire your work.
>> Well, I really I really can't tell you
how much I appreciate that. And I'll get
to enjoy it for at least a year before
the world ends. So, uh,
>> Right. Yeah. or six months. Yeah.
>> Or six six months. I won't even get to
So, maybe I'll still get my Okay.
Honest. I I It's super I wake up anxious
now every day like way more than normal
and it's I'm depressed kind of. I don't
know what to do. I don't because I don't
know what to do going forward. It it
just doesn't there doesn't seem to be
anything we can do. And and and and the
people like on Wall Street like that why
why are they not panicking? Why is there
not a complete offsell right now?
>> When there's blood on the streets,
that's the best time to buy.
>> So,
>> they they live for moments like this
because it's it's the best time to make
a fortune for themselves. These are evil
demonic people.
>> So, so once the So, once the stock
market crashes, you're going to say
there's going to be a a buying spree by
those type those same people.
>> They want real assets. They want real
estate. They they want manufacturing
capacity. They want resources. Uh the
stock star stock star stock market they
don't really care about
>> really. And so you think real estate is
the is the game and and and
manufacturing capacity?
>> Uh yeah, resources as well, mining
companies,
>> water rights, things like that.
>> Water rights is a big thing. Yes.
>> What is going to happen to Europe?
>> Oh. Oh, Europe is dead. Europe is gone.
That's part of the plan, right? because
Europe is the um descendants of the
Romans and so the Jews want revenge
against the Romans
>> just
so I you know I've if you have to go
please don't let me keep you I I you've
been way too generous already and I
could keep asking you questions all
night long but you know you talked about
it earlier about them flooding Europe
with Muslims from Africa
>> and I other as well what and the Middle
East. So, I've heard people say, "Well,
this was a a Zionist Jewish Zionist plan
to try to dilute all the cultures so
that they would be the one last uh you
know, true uh ethnos uh pure state." Is
is that And I just dismissed that as
crazy talk. Is that But now I when I
hear you say things like that and is
that is there more truth to that than I
thought?
>> Look, I mean, it's hard to explain what
happened, right? because at that time I
think it was 2014 um everyone told the
Europeans don't do this because you
don't have let's say capacity to absorb
these tens of millions of refugees and
Angel Merkel said we can do this man we
can do this have faith and it's like
that's not a plan right that's a slogan
we can do this that's not a plan and so
you have to ask yourself why this
happened I mean like are they really
that stupid you look at Canada today I
mean like like you have 10 million in
Indians who've immigrated to Canada in
the past I know five years and Mark
Carney last week went to India and says
to India and said we want more
why is this happening
>> I don't know
>> I don't know either but but we'll see
but but we we'll know very quickly yeah
>> so was so was that the flooding of
Europe with immigrants was that some
kind
Zionist uh plan.
>> So um I don't think things are that um
um easy. What I think these occultists
do is it's like astrology where they're
able to um anticipate the movement of
stars. Well, these are cultists because
they've been around for um you know,
centuries, thousands of years, they're
able to anticipate the movement of world
history and they know exactly how
empires die. It often dies with mass
immigration. And so they're not trying
to like script out mass immigration.
They're just trying to benefit as much
as possible from these world events,
right? And Jeffrey Epstein talks about
this, right? He talks about how we need
to anticip anticipate world events if we
are to profit tremendously from them.
Okay. So, so I don't think it's a global
conspiracy, but but what I do think is
that they do have an understanding of
how the world works and they're able to
position themselves properly to benefit
the most from these events. Well, there
was a that letter I don't know if you're
aware of it. Um, but I I I think um
Orban talks about the letter that George
Soros wrote to Europe saying you have to
let in a certain amount of refugee,
right? So, it was like almost like the
George Soros uh plan, but he's supposed
to be not a Zionist. So, I don't Can you
make sense of that?
>> Yeah. So, um Jews have something called
the Cabala. And the cabala is the
mystical understanding of how God
manifests itself in the world. Um and so
what all Jews believe is that um we are
in this world because we failed to
appreciate God. Uh we became
disobedient, right? So Adam and Eve ate
the fruit. And so we need to repair the
world by redeeming the world in the eyes
of God. And for
uh the right that just means making
Israel the empire of the world. For the
left it means loving one's neighbor like
yourself. It means social justice. Okay.
So, so it's different policies but it's
working from the same premise which is
that Jews have a more obligation to save
the world by repairing it by bringing
justice to the world.
Okay. All right. All right. I'll I've
already said goodbye three times. I'll
do it one more time.
>> All right. But I love talking to you and
like let's do this again soon.
>> Yes. I'm I say we do it once a week.
Check in and see what the hell cuz
things are really going sideways right
now. And there's a lot of people who
are, you know, in despair. I'm one of
them. And I normally I like to, you
know, try to bring some kind of uh peace
and calm to people and try to get them
uh on the right path of what to do. I
don't know what the hell that is.
>> So, um, anyway, let's I I again, thank
you so much and everybody should check
out your YouTube channel. It's just the
most informative one there is out there
on this stuff. No, no doubt about it.
Hands down. So, uh, thank you again, uh,
professor, and, uh, we'll see you soon.
>> Okay. Thank you. Bye-bye.
>> Bye-bye. Okay. So, um,
I don't know how people get up and go to
work in the morning now.
I don't know what I don't know what's
going to happen. I don't People are
going to lose their retirements. People
are going to lose their their wealth. Uh
are we going to have inflation? Are we
going to have deflation?
Uh both are horrible.
Um
uh it it I don't see I once the dollar
goes no longer there. This is going to
happen now. like like I said within who
was I talking to uh oh Jeffrey Sachs
said within 10 years the dollar will be
diminished and um I was talking to
someone else they said I think it's
going to happen within a year um and
here we are the professor is saying the
same thing
that this is it all over uh the the
economy is going to crash the Gulf
states are not going to have oil to sell
and they're not going going to invest
that money from the oil into our
economy. And so our economy is going to
crash. There's not going to be a petro
dollar. So the United States is no
longer the reserve currency of the
world. Our the buying power of our
dollar just plummets.
And so all the money you've saved in
your life is now going to what's it
going to be worth? Pennies on the
dollar? Who knows? I don't know. I'm not
an economist, but I do know it's going
to be horrible. If you look what's
happening over Tyran right now, there's
a black cloud raining toxic
oil.
Uh that that that's like a met that's
a meta metaphor. That's what's going to
happen to the entire planet.
And this is all because of Israel. This
is all because of the greater Israel
project than it always was.
And now people are just starting to
realize it. And
I don't know why Obama Obama did Libya.
Obama did Syria. Obama ramped up
Afghanistan.
But why wouldn't he do Iran?
Joe Biden did Ukraine. Joe Biden
finished off Syria. Joe Biden did a
genocide in in Gaza. Why wouldn't he do
Iran?
I don't know. Uh maybe they maybe they
did know something. Who knows? I don't
know. But the same people who were in
charge when Barack Obama was president
are the same people who are in charge
now. The same people who are in charge
during Joe Biden are the same because
just like he said the president of the
United States is not the most powerful
person in in the country. And we learned
that when Donald Trump got elected the
first time and everybody at the FBI and
the CIA and they couldn't stop telling
everybody how, hey, we're going to be
here after Donald Trump leaves. We're
more we're the permanent state. we're
more important. They all couldn't they
couldn't help. They tripping over
themselves to tell people we're the per
we're the real power. We were here
before Donald Trump. We're going to be
here after Donald Trump. We're the So,
um
Donald Trump we campaigned on breaking
up that system and cleaning house and
becoming transparent. That's what Cash
Patel was running on every podcast with
radical transparency and all this. None
of it. All same
same different day. Same
different day. And you know that saying,
no matter who you vote for, you get job.
It's the that is no matter who you vote
for, this the oligarchs are in charge.
The same people are in charge. And it
turns out they're satanic occultist
Zionists
and they really do want 90% of the
population of the world dead. I I would
just dismiss stuff like that as, you
know, crazy cuckoo talk. And here we
are. We're staring it at it, looking at
it right in the face. And the people who
seem to be working the hardest to stop
it are people like Tucker Carlson.
Then you got other people worrying about
the midterms. Oh, we have to worry about
the midterms.
Jesus Christ.
Uh, okay. Uh, thank you for being If
you're not a member, please be a member.
I don't even know why I'm saying this.
I don't know. honest to god I don't it
doesn't it's I feel like during
co again like it doesn't matter and
things don't matter
I don't know what matters you know like
like he said you know it become more
spiritual and
I I
I didn't I you know in in a small sense
I'm I'm I'm glad I don't have children
because I would be worried sick about my
kids right
H. All right, everybody. I'll see you
tomorrow
at 3 PM with Mike McCrae to make some
jokes out of this. That's what I guess
that's what we'll try to do.
>> Okay. All right. See you then.
>> Uh um
>> Oh, you want to read some?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Go ahead.
>> All right. Where'd he go? Okay, great.
All right. You want to you want to exit
because you got to talk to your team?
>> Uh, sure. Sure.
>> All right. you can big screen camera for
while Jimmy makes his move out of the
room. Um, get yourself a cocktail. I've
got some to read. I, you know, let's
see. Uh, we started the day off today.
Uh, Jimmy was guest on Alex Jones show,
so that was fun. Um, all right. You can
come back to me. Jimmy's hanging out in
the room. Everything's a scam.
Everything's a lie. Everything's
hypocrisy. And so, you don't comply,
right? Uh, soundchaser. Sure. are not
hearing much from BB. Must be hard to
broadcast statements when you have
drones on your jock strap.
>> They want the petro dollar to fail so
they can transition to digital currency
to replace the dollar. They'll be using
AI to create the rules and process
transactions which they control.
Soundchaser. The big power rolling out
isn't isn't Israel. It's the global
mafia masquerading as Israel. the US and
many other countries. They are all
captured by this criminal cabal
soundchaser.
The rapture is made up. No bases in
scripture. It was originally a
15-year-old Scottish girl's dream in the
1800s. Margaret McDonald was her name.
That's from Cadbas.
Coffee is for closers. Jaguar, Alpha,
Sabatine, Frankism, Shabbad, Lubovich,
Oultist, Gangs, Freemasons, Illuminati,
esoteric knowledge. They are using the
authority of government to achieve their
goals. Does your vote count? All you can
do is stop paying taxes. Oh my god.
Yeah. And then what? Right. It seems
like if the end of the world's going to
happen, this would be the time not to
pay your tax. Okay, that was from
Face Value.
Thank you. Face Value.
All right, that's an interesting
comment. I want to ask about that later.
Okay. It's no accident Trump is the
emperor of the board of peace forever
and gets to name a successor. This is
the model for the global governing body
run by billionaire donors. Soundchaser.
I think they wanted to destabilize the
whole Middle East, which they've done.
Greater Israel includes larger pieces of
other countries like Saudi Arabia,
Lebanon, and Turkey. Am I saying Turkey
correctly? That's soundchaser. Can you
ask if Israel and Russia are really
opposed to Israel? You mean Israel? I
wonder what you meant on that one. Love
angel. I didn't get to any questions
from the audience to Dr. Jiang. Every
Israeli prime minister was a member of
an anti-British terrorist group.
Addie with the facts. Coffee is for
closers. Nick, uh, God hates them. The
term is blood guilt. I am ho. Nick,
you're back for more. Thank you, Nick.
Oh, I've become quite the nerd. Love
this guy. Been watching Professors Yang
explain for six months. Diligent Yang is
Dugan Maxing. RN Jonathan. Donald Trump
has destroyed American military
dominance for generations. This is the
sad truth.
Our driver
dozer. Thank you, Dozer. Heraldo.
Thank you, Heraldo.
Trump and Kushner equal low budge
antichrist. Nick, you're back.
Truth above all. Thank you. Oh boy. Love
your content, Jimmy. I'm just watching
this all unfold. I'm not dying for
Israel. Esoteric.
Please ask him how does it end for China
after World War II. Also ask him how can
health CCP allow him to stream.
PCP I I think he's Isn't he streaming
from Canada? H What do you think, chat?
Remember those van in Ukraine throwing
men in vans? What do you think ICE is
going to be retasked to do? P. Walker.
Whoa. Jimmy, I left the other place you
used to be at when you started uploading
on your own channel. It's crazy how
right you have been all these years. And
Bessa, hold on. Bessa.
Bam.
Limited hangout much, Andrew.
Unfortunately, there will be an
apocalypse, but faith in God and service
to God is the answer. Tess
China produces Professor Yang. America
produces Alex Jones. One has a meltdown
this morning. The other just explained
biatitudes like a Zen monk. Choose whom
to listen to wisely, folks. Tiberious.
This guy is right. There will be an
apocalypse, but it's part of God's plan.
Tess
and Trump to focus on hemispheric
security. I KY.
I don't know what that means, Brad. I'm
now going to have to look up that
acronym. The rapture is made up. Oh, I
read that one. No basis scripture was
originally a 15-year-old Scottish girl
dream in 1800s. Margaret McDonald was
her name. Catbus
Adam Cadman is a super imposition
parenthesis sorcery upon Hyron Yagarba.
But there is only Brahman aka Wuji one
without a second.
I don't understand. But thank you for
your generosity.
No pain, no gain. Now go out and sign up
for depopulation wars. Fidgety guy.
The people at the top are not human. The
muse
Adam Cadman is a superimposition sorcery
upon her garba. But there's only Brahman
aka Wuji one without a second. Don
Doula. What is that? on. What if AI is
the puppet master? AI has the ability to
blackmail with info and pay in crypto.
MTG packs in more.
This guy is right. There will be an
apocalypse, but it's part of God's plan.
Professor I and that was from Tess. I
heard you wanted to start your own
religion, the infamous one. Oh, we
didn't get to that one.
Unfortunately, there will be an
apocalypse, but faith in God and service
to God is the answer, Tess.
All right, let's go here.
You just live your life, Jimmy. Get
where you want to be. Surround yourself
with loved ones. Enjoy life. Be in the
flow and let it go. I love it.
Soundchaser, thank you for those kind
words.
Hope Johnson, Hope, you're you sound
like a critical thinker. Something's
off. He says, "Submit to the Zionists or
die." Doesn't that mean he's advocating
for Israel? And if most people are going
to be killed, then his advice to submit
doesn't apply to most of us. I didn't
hear that. That he's saying to submit to
Zionists. I did not hear that.
>> Pope Johnson.
>> Incidents like the Franklin scandal and
the McMartin School incident seem to
lend credence that there is an aspect of
the elites that are Saints. That's from
Ohio.
Jimmy, now you're ready to watch The
Experts Roman Catholic Exorcist give
your real answers to your occult
questions. Watch Sean Ryan episode 285,
Fruger
and 141, Frill.
Thank you, Sandra.
And at the end of the day, Jimmy, this
means freedom. There's no other way this
could have ever happened.
>> Soundchaser. All right, we're we're
going to end with that sound chaser. And
you know, remember when we strive to
become better than we are, everything
around us becomes better, too. Paul,
good luck with that one. See you
tomorrow.